ladies it is a fact of life our bodies
go through significant changes as we age
but one expert wants women to know that
perimenopause and menopause are not just
phases in our lives they can be
associated with some very serious
diseases
we really need to start prioritizing our
health and making this um a topic that
we speak about a little bit more openly
Dr Kavita Desai says women need to be
having a lot more discussions about
perimenopause the precursor to menopause
we all hear about hot flashes difficulty
sleeping and fatigue some women notice
as early as their mid-30s others go
through it closer to age 50. but she
says there are so many other symptoms
that can be very serious some of them
actually quite debilitating things like
heart palpitation tinnitus which is
ringing in the ears you know dry itchy
skin it can lead to osteoporosis and
bone loss Dr Desai says women need
estrogen and progesterone to feel our
best as we're losing these hormones we
need to make changes to our lifestyles
the first what we consume avoid
processed carbs and sugar we do not
process sugars the same once we start to
go through menopause without our
estrogen our insulin sensitivity changes
so changing diet to a more Whole Foods
lots of plant-based foods and you know
clean meat like protein protein sources
move more burn those extra calories
strength train as you need to build
muscle during this time try to manage
your sleep routine as it often becomes
disruptive and find a way to better
manage stress during our perimenopausal
years with the loss of estrogen we tend
to have increased stress levels increase
anxiety a lot of depression so again
that's something that we should be
focusing on with more mindfulness
meditation yoga
she adds supplements can help with a lot
of the symptoms and inflammation
increase your Omega-3s find a good
vitamin D and B complex ashwagandha and
Rhodiola can also help reduce stress